c'est vrai quoi la 52% disent connais
pas faire c'est essentiel bonjour michel
il va directement en grande surface mais
pour les autres c'est plus qu'une coupe
de cheveux un coiffeur c'est pour ça que
la question est compliquée mais cet
accord des lieux c'est comme laisser les
centres esthétiques ce sont des lieux de
sociabilité où des gens notamment je
pense à la région parisienne beaucoup de
vieilles personnes seules vont chez le
coiffeur ou sans prêter pour trouver de
la compagnie chez le leader montréjeau
sont seules chez elles
et ça c'est très dangereux faut pas
rompre le lien social avec nos aînés
notamment ce serait tragique mais
valérie non mais à ce compte là le lien
social tu peux le tice est partout donc
à ce compte là il n'y a ignoré alors que
des exceptions ou et oui tout le monde
dirait en regardant son nombril oui mais
moi je suis essentielle à un moment il
faut oublier son nombril à un moment il
faut oublier son moi oui il y aura des
gens qui vont être sur le carreau et
d'allumer je fais de toi mon essentiel
non mais oui ça va ça m c'est
extrêmement douloureux pour beaucoup de
gens évidemment pour les coiffeurs c'est
extrêmement douloureux parce qu'il y en
a qui vont certainement mettre la clé
sous la porte parce qu'ils n'arrivent
rompt pas à passer outre cette zone euro
pourraient mal à les soutenir mais
malheureusement indiqué il ya un moment
où l intérêt suprême l'intérêt de la
collectivité est au dessus de l'intérêt
individuel c'est désolant c'est que mes
mais malheureusement il va falloir faire
ça mais bon pas et c'est désolant parce
que c'est tout comme un diable c'est du
cas par cas et après comme annie
philippe chacun voit son nombril et vous
rend compte qu'on est arrivé dans une
situation où tout le monde est en train
de se fermer les uns les autres parce
qu'on est en train de dire pourquoi
l'huile est ouvert avec ça je ferme
exactement dommage la ferme ta vue on
peut pas acheter un livre rue de la
liberté à colmar alors qu'on serait 3
dans cette librairie alors que chez
leclerc chez carrefour et chaussants ils
sont 250 attendait rien alors on va
fermer les livres dans les rayons c'est
ça qui devient triste le coiffeur aussi
c'est pareil pourquoi on pourrait pas se
dire à 3 dans un salon de coiffure avec
des masques la coiffeuse avec un masque
et où est ce que tu fais du mannequin
mais les cas par cas comme ça résultat
des courses on a pu fermer et parce
qu'il faut faire plaisir à tout le monde
et puis le philippe l'a dit valérie l'a
dit on se sauve d'abord nous et on
reviendra chez le coiffeur après on
retournera au théâtre après on ira à
lire des livres après mais en fait vous
tuez pas les mecs qui lisent les livres
parce qu'on est libre les achetons sur
internet vous tuez des libraires en
train de tuer chaque catégorie comme ça
pour faire plaisir à l'autre un hareng
pourquoi on arrêtait les livres chez
leclerc ou à carrefour parce qu'il ya
des libraires qu'on dit c'est pas normal
en grandes surfaces ils les vendent
on prend le problème
à l'envers et ouais on prend le premier
lieu de laisser les librairies on ferme
la librairie dans le clair et oui c'est
les restaurants je suis dedans je peux
comprendre parce qu'on enlève le masque
en restant et c'est dramatique ce qui va
se passer
c'est fou ce qui va se passer bien mais
je suis pas le mieux armé pour une
chambre surpris par vraiment pas ce qui
est en général raymond non mais résume
toujours les choses de la manière la
plus claire qui soit vous l'aimez show
là que je voudrais dire c'est que ce que
nous montre en fait la situation c'est
que confiné un peu est une absurdité
interdire un peu est d'une absurdité 12
à 13 ans et comprendra confinement total
non mais c'est bon on entend parler d'un
contrat de formation dans l'est dans les
termes sûr que si on confine on confine
bah oui là le problème c'est que tout le
monde se sent plus ou moins concernés
donc celui qui se confirme va voir des
gens qui se promènent dehors de m'avoir
des gens qui travaillent et on ne voit
que des cas particuliers autour de nous
ça que des exceptions et l'exception et
les limites des généralités par
définition sur les coiffeurs c'est un
drame parce que les coiffeurs ont un
rôle symbolique
quand on va chez le coiffeur c'est une
nouvelle vie qui commence on se sent
régénérer non mais c'est vrai pour tout
le monde y en a raté les séries les
quiches ou psychologiques dont le fait
d'aller chez le coiffeur cantons seront
en général quand on sort de chez le
coiffeur on se sent ensemble vous s'en
vont ensemble lors se son intelligence
en mai dans sa peau on s'en va on a
généré jo bats dans les cheveux et donc
je crois que psychologiquement
vous savez c'est la même chose une
librairie le coiffeur s'apprennent de
civilisation la civilisation inventé le
fait de se couper les cheveux parce que
on devient barbare avec les cheveux
longs on pense pas la même chose avec
les cheveux longs qu'avec seulement 30
secondes le cheminement
on se sent galante on va chez le
coiffeur on se sent beau quand on veut
acheter un livre on se sent beau aussi
quand on va acheter un jean et un pull
sur me sens beau et quand je vais au
restaurant pour aller par là qu'une nana
je me sens bosnie tout cheminement alors
je vais vous parler
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'essentiel oui à 56 pour sa ville
tenons à 44 11 56% mello c'est vrai que
c'est dans la tête le corps et un mois
il avait dans l'appellation d' essentiel
il ya quand même mais j'ai pas si vous
êtes d'accord john extrêmement humiliant
parce que vous vous êtes essentielles
vous n'êtes pas mais il faut quand même
dire une chose pour la personne qui
s'est endetté pour 10 ans à gaza
c'est essentiel c'est que soit la
l'occupation et la raison ceux ci un
accord donc le mot essentiel c'est comme
vous savez la distance sociale
il ya quand même des expressions chez
nos gouvernants qui sont extrêmement
blessant pour les gens
il avait alors les salons se sont
endettés pas sur moi qui vais
régulièrement puisque je veux vous dire
que ça ressemble plus à des salles des
salles d'hôpital c'est à dire que les
conditions d'asepsie fait de la façon
dont ils aseptise tout c'est absolument
incroyable
les fameux truc en plastique il ya les
trucs de main à l'entrée on n'enlève
jamais le masque pour cautériser bien ce
que c'est essentiel non pas pour vous le
jeu reconnaît jean-michel ici la
coiffure on peut s'en passer mais
l'épilation fou que ça reste merci 5
c'est beaucoup de terre
pourtant paix malheureusement
c'est la triste réalité